The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
INSTRUCTOR: So
welcome to the lab.
I'm going to start off
today-- mostly everything
we'll do is be hands on.
I'm going to start
out today just
to reiterate some of the
things that we talked about
last Monday, and to expand
on a few of those ideas
about what we're doing here.
And the idea of this
little introductory lecture
is just to say,
what's our purpose?
What's the expectations?
What are we doing here?
Pretty much every place you go
there's a set of expectations
of what you're
expected to do and what
you're expected
to be done to you.
And it's very different
depending on what you do.
If you go to a
baseball game, it's
a totally different
set of expectations
of both what you're
allowed and prepared to do
and what you're expecting to see
then if you went to a concert
or if you went to
a physics class.
All different stuff.
All different sets
of expectations.
All different ideas about
what we're doing here.
So this little
thing is to give you
an idea of what this is about.
What we're doing here.
The first thing-- which to me
is the most important thing
we already touched on in the
last class-- which is just
the idea that we're
all improvisers.
That simply by virtue
of being a human,
you're already a
master improviser.
Where I go from there is that
humans are also oral creatures.
We understand the world
through sound a lot.
Not only through
talking, not only
through our experience of
the sounds of other humans,
but also the sounds
in the world inform us
all the time in all
different kinds of ways.
And also each of us grows up
surrounded by music and sound.
We all have a personal
universe of sound that is ours.
In this class and in this
lab, what we'll be doing
a lot is dealing with how to
marry our awareness that we
have from growing up
as improvising people
to our awareness of our
understanding of sound.
Our personal universe of sound.
Putting those two
things together
and figuring out how to express
ourselves improvisationally
through using sound.
Both individually
and as a group.
So that's our basic
task ahead of us.
In this particular
class, we're doing that
by examining different
ways that people improvise.
Different methods that people
use to structure improvisation.
Different ways that they use to
conceptualize how to improvise.
Because as improvisers,
you come up here
and when you're improvising
without any music
or without any prior structure,
anything is possible.
That's an overwhelming
responsibility.
You could do literally anything.
How do you decide what to do?
So that's the
first part of being
an improviser is
how do you start?
How do you start?
And a lot of this class
is about how people start.
Today I think Mark was talking
about graphic notation,
I think in some kinds of ways.
To conceptualize improvising
starting with something
that's visual.
A way to start.
And from this, then that
gives you a starting off point
where you can use
your understanding,
your intuition
about improvising.
Your understanding, your
knowledge about sound.
How it works, what it means.
You can use all that
stuff to say OK, that's
my starting point.
How do I use that stuff
starting from here?
So a lot of this
class is about that.
How do you start?
Where do you come from?
The other thing that's great
about this kind of class,
this kind of improvisation,
this kind of group
is that there's no particular
stylistic boundaries
to what we're doing.
In a lot of different musical
situations you go into,
there's a set of boundaries just
like if you go to the ballpark.
There's a set of boundaries
of what's going to happen.
You go to a jazz concert or
you play in a jazz big band.
There's a set of boundaries
of what you expect to happen
and you can-- pretty
much everything
you do is going to
be within that pretty
well established
set of boundaries.
In this situation, we
don't have any of those.
The boundaries that
we have-- there's
some set up by the structure
of the class, which
is bringing in these different
artists who specialize
in different ways of
conceptualizing improvisation,
but outside of
that-- and looking
at those specific
artists and ideas
that Mark's looking at in the
class-- outside of that there's
no particular boundaries
to how we improvise
or what we do together
when we improvise.
The only boundaries are ones
that we set up in the moment,
and the way we set this
up is through a series
of structured improvisations.
So most of the work
we're doing here
is examining improvisation
or examining music
through the use of structured
improvisational exercises.
There are ways to say what
happens if you do this.
Just like when you're talking
today about graphic notation.
What happens if you do
this and you say play it?
So we'll work a lot
with structured--
and there are ways
to look at something
on a microscopic level.
To go and look at
something closely.
A particular aspect of
improvisation or of music.
And then once you
examine it, bring it
into your conscious awareness,
then all that understanding
that you have is then
available for you
to use in a bigger context
where you're improvising.
Whether you're improvising
on a squiggle or on a mode
or on giant steps.
So what we'll do is we'll
take these specific exercises,
hone in really closely
on little-- small ideas,
and then we'll use those in
a freer context hopefully
later on to improvise
together as a group.
So that's the second thing.
There's no particular boundary.
So you're able to use your
entire personal universe
of sound to improvise with.
And what that means is there's
no right and there's no wrong.
So remember when we
were talking about how--
making this a safe
place to improvise.
Making this a safe place
to show who you are
and to be who you
are in the moment.
One of the reasons why it's safe
is because there's no judgment.
Because there's no
boundaries set up
by a particular style of music.
There's no judgment about
what's a right or a wrong sound.
what sounds can go together.
Any sound can go
with any other sound.
So what we're
concerned with is not
judging which sounds
are right or wrong
when you put them together.
We're concerned with
what does it mean?
What does it feel like?
Did putting those
sounds together express
what you wanted it to express?
Did it mean what you
wanted it to mean?
Did it have the effect
on the people that
were observing you do it
that you wanted it to have?
So it's really all
sonic experimentation
that we're doing together.
Using these elements of
improvisation and of music
and of sound that we've grown
up with our entire lives
to say OK, if we do this
and this, what does it do?
What does it mean?
How does it work?
Do I like it or
do I not like it?
Does he like it ?
Does he not like it?
It's awful.
The other thing that Mark also
mentioned in the first class--
but I think is
worth reiterating--
is that this is really
about having fun.
Improvisation should be fun.
It should be fun in every
way that you can have fun.
So it should be crazy fun,
it should be silly fun,
it should be totally,
serious intense fun.
The kind of fun where you're
so engrossed in something
that you lose all track of time.
The kind of fun where
you're looking at formulas
and figuring out how they work.
All the kinds of
fun you could think
of that you can have
up here improvising,
and that's what it should
ultimately be about.
I think that's about
all the things.
We'll do some more, but
that's basically-- just
to give you an idea of
where we're at here.
And I mentioned before that the
other really important thing--
but I'll reiterate that
too-- is that it's important
that you tell the truth.
That really what
makes the difference
between an improvisation
that is compelling,
that grips your audience, and
one that people sort of fall
asleep or run away from is
are you telling the truth?
Are you expressing yourself?
Are you showing yourself?
If you could do that.
If you start from there, then
every note, every phrase,
every sound you play is
going to have meaning.
And over the course
of this class,
we'll figure out different
ways to approach it.
Different kinds of
meaning that you can have.
And you'll get a
chance to experiment
with different
ideas of your own.
To see what your personal
universe of sound
contributes to this group.
Into what we do as improvisers.
So today I was think
and we'd start off--
since we're dealing
with graphic notation
and I think we're going
into some stuff with film
improvising the
film later-- we're
going to skip over a lot
of things I would usually
do in the beginning group and
go into some more stuff that's
related to more visual
parameters and movement.
Different things that
you might be encountering
in the course of your next
few classes and your next few
assignments.
So what I'd like to do is
start off with an exercise.
We'll all come up
without instruments.
A lot of times I'll start
off with some theater
exercises or
exercises that don't
involve instruments
as a warm up.
So we are filming today,
so usually I'd do a circle,
but I think for the
sake of the camera,
we'll do sort of
like a semicircle
if you can just get in a
big arc here so you can all
see each other but
still leave an opening
so we're not staring in
the back of anybody's head.
This exercise is a
very simple exercise.
It's about movement and sound,
and the way it works is this.
One person comes out here
to the center, or actually,
thinking of the
camera placement.
The center might
not work so good.
Might have just a step
forward from where you are,
and what you're
going to do is you're
going to make a
gesture and a sound.
It can be anything.
It can be any kind of
gesture, any kind of sound,
and you're going to repeat it.
And then everybody else is
going to repeat it with you.
Does that make sense?
And then after we
do it for a while,
everybody gets into the groove,
it's how we got it going on,
then you're going to go
and take someone's place
and they're going to
step out and do theirs.
And so on until everybody
gets a chance to do it.
Yeah?
All right.
So, I'll start.
Let's see.
We might need to
get a little space
in between each other just in
case there's movement involved.
All right.
Boing!
ALL: Boing!
Boing Boing!
Boing!
[GROANING]
[CLEARING THROAT]
[POPPING SOUND]
INSTRUCTOR: Just be
aware that everything
that the person does
actually has meaning.
So their facial expression--
everything that they're doing
is potential.
[WHISTLING]
[DRUMMING SOUND]
AUDIENCE: Bada!
ALL: Bada!
Bada!
[SCREECHING SOUND]
AUDIENCE: Ding-dong.
ALL: Ding-dong.
Ding-dong.
[SNEEZING]
[DEFLATION SOUND]
[DRUMMING]
[MEOWING]
[GRUNTING]
AUDIENCE: Who hasn't gone?
INSTRUCTOR: I don't know.
Is anybody left?
Did everybody go?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Yeah?
Woo!
INSTRUCTOR: Haha, good.
Excellent.
Now the interesting thing
about this to me, and it's
really fascinating
and fun every time
is that we do associate
movement and sound.
There was no accident that
you chose this movement
to go with that sound or that
sound to go with this movement.
There's connections
we have in our brains
about what kind of
movement sound like what.
And what kind of sounds would
be what kind of movement.
So we're going on
sped up time here,
so what I'd like to do
is get some instruments
and what I want to do
is have some people
move and some people play.
Let's go in half.
So we'll have-- so,
just for now-- let's see
one, two, three, four, five six.
We'll have you all play and
you all are going to move.
I include you when I say play.
It's all play.
All instrumenting is playing.
So here's the thing.
Here's what I want to do
is-- oh, yeah, let's do that.
Yeah.
Let's just switch with somebody.
Why don't we switch you since
you don't have an instrument
to pick up what those guys
are already picking up.
So, let's do this.
There's a lot of-- I've never
done it quite this way before,
so let's experiment some
and see how this works.
All you people, what
I want you to do
is you have all this
space to move in.
You can move however you want.
OK?
You can walk around,
you can turn around,
you can stand still.
Whatever you want to do.
Each of you.
I want each of you to pick one
of these people and play them.
Make sounds that you think
go with how they're moving.
OK?
No, we'll all go at once.
Chaos is good in the
beginning especially.
Less stress.
Ready?
All right?
Get set.
Go.
[VARIOUS MUSIC PLAYING]
INSTRUCTOR: All right.
Guys, guys!
I gotcha now.
You guys look like you're done.
You guys look like
you're done over here.
Good, so do you guys-- do
you know who was playing you?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
INSTRUCTOR: Yup.
Anybody else?
Anybody else feel did you
catch that correspondence
between who was playing you?
No?
Who were you playing?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
INSTRUCTOR: Anybody else?
AUDIENCE: Me too.
I think it was the tall
blond-haired thing.
INSTRUCTOR: He made the most
dramatic movement initially,
which attracts attention.
Which is-- the other
interesting thing
is that you were
moving in such a--
you were moving initially in
a very rhythmic way, which
allowed him to set up that
rhythmic correspondence.
And sort of everything
in the group
sort of revolved around that.
You remember we were talking
in the first class about how
when you set up a pulse,
when you set up a rhythm.
It just attracts things to it.
Yeah, it just does because
we're-- that's how we survive.
Right?
Without rhythm we
would all be dead.
Literally.
Right?
It's the rhythmic
beating of our heart.
It's the rhythmic bleeding
in and out of our bodies.
It's all these rhythmic
movements inside of us
that enable us to keep living.
Our process is a rhythmic
process as humans.
Sleep and wake, you know?
I mean we're surrounded
by our rhythmic universe.
So, we're attracted to it.
And we see that.
We understand the sense of that.
Really fast.
Faster than other
kinds of things.
So it's just something to be
aware of as an improviser.
When you set up a pulse
or when you set up
a rhythm that repeats, it's
going to attract attention
and it's going to--
people are going
to go to it until you
repeat it for too long
and then they're not
going to hear it anymore.
Like the air conditioner
that goes on in the room.
You hear it's
really loud at first
and then you don't hear it.
So rhythm is like that, too.
If you repeat the same rhythm
over and over and over again,
after a certain amount,
people stop hearing it.
So that's another challenge
when we're dealing with groove
and rhythm is how to keep
it alive and fresh even
though it's repetitious.
Let's switch roles.
I'm going to say a lot
of different things
and basically I say
what comes into my head
based on what happens, you know?
Things that I see that I
think might be interesting
or might give you some kind
of little insight, little idea
about how improvisation works.
I don't expect you to
particularly remember
it all or even
think about it much,
but I do expect that--
a lot of this process
is about bringing
things to your awareness
because we all mostly
understand and have dealt
with improvisation in
our lives as a completely
unconscious process.
It's something we
use continually
all the time throughout
our entire lives,
and probably-- unless you're a
jazz player-- no one has ever
even mentioned it or talk to
you at all about how it works.
Which is, to me, shocking.
So we hope to rectify
that a little bit in this
because basically
every innovation
springs out of a moment
of improvisation.
So the more aware
you can be, the more
things about improvisation--
tools of improvisation
that you are aware of and can
bring into your consciousness
and work with
consciously, the more able
you're going to
be to be creative.
To be innovative no matter
what it is that you're doing.
All right, so we split up?
We got our two groups?
And go!
[MUSIC PLAYING]
INSTRUCTOR: Good.
Good, good, good.
That was a nice ending place.
One of the things I think we'll
have to work on fairly soon--
I don't think today, but
maybe next time-- is ending.
We'll do a little session
on beginnings and endings.
But for right now
I'll just stop you.
Or you can stop for yourself
if you feel like it's done.
Right.
So now, let's switch this.
So now what I want
to happen is I
want the people that are
moving to pick a person that's
playing, and move
how they're playing.
Now you guys are just
going to start playing.
Improvising together.
And at this point,
don't worry too much
about what you're doing.
Just have some fun.
Just like we were when
you came out and did
a sound and a motion.
And then you all
who are moving are
going to pick one of the
people that are making sounds
and you're going to
move to their sounds.
What's that?
AUDIENCE: Should we try and
play something together?
INSTRUCTOR: I don't think you
should try too much anything
right now.
A lot of times when
you're improvising,
if you try too much it makes
it really hard to improvise.
And one of the great
things actually
about doing structured
improvisations,
which is the secret goal of
a structured improvisation,
is to give your mind-- your
conscious mind, your monkey
mind, something to latch
onto-- so that you can actually
improvise freely.
So yeah, I don't think
too much about it yet.
We'll give you more things to
think about as we go along.
For now, I think it's
just important to have
some fun making sounds.
I mean, the interesting thing--
if you were paying attention
on these last two exercises--
the interesting thing is
the music was actually
very interesting.
You guys actually
did play together
even though that
wasn't our objective,
and you certainly didn't
have any thing to say,
oh, you're going
to move together,
you're going to play together.
The fact is that
people-- you get
a group of people in any
situation doing something
together, and they're
going to-- doing stuff.
They're going to start
to do it together.
Just how we work.
As you get better
as an improviser
and more conscious and more
aware of the possibilities
that are around and what
your personal preferences
and possibilities
are, then you'll
be able to be more conscious
about being together.
You'll have more choices.
But right now I
think we can just
rely on our natural instinct
to make things sound good
and be together.
And not think about.
OK, ready?
OK, here, let's just
do this for a second.
Because this is
going to be harder.
Because-- well, it might not be.
See, like I'm already
putting expectations on you.
It might-- it's just going
to be totally easy, actually.
Let's just-- ready?
Let's go.
Go!.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
INSTRUCTOR: We're
going stop here.
Stop.
Let's try this again.
I'm going to add one thing.
One is I want you guys to
feel free to come into here.
So you have all this space.
It's a little
intimidating, but you
have all this space to do stuff.
So let's use this space.
You guys, I want you to also be
aware of the rest of the group.
We'll say that now, because--
but be aware of them
in the same way that you
were aware of the people that
were moving.
You know, like when
the people were moving
and you guys were playing.
You were aware of what
everybody was playing,
but you weren't that
worried about it.
You were just playing stuff that
felt good and related to what's
going on.
Let's do the same thing.
All right, you ready?
Let's do it one more time.
Same groups.
So here-- everybody come out.
Let's all spread out in here
just so you're in a space
already.
You don't have to
inhabit the space.
You could just be in the space.
And now I want you
guys-- before we
start-- to pick one of
the people to move to.
So then you'll know--
you know already
when you're going to
move and when you're not.
You guys that are playing?
Don't feel like you all
have to start at once.
Wait, let's add this.
This is fun.
Let's wait until
you actually feel
an impulse to make a sound,
and then make a sound.
OK?
So that's our structure.
Wait until you have an
impulse to make a sound.
Then make the sound.
As soon as you don't have
that impose anymore, stop.
You guys pick ahead of
time before they even
start playing who
you're moving to.
And let's go!
[MUSIC PLAYING]
INSTRUCTOR: OK, wait a second!
Let's stop again.
I gave you a bad start for this.
Hold on, let's stop.
Let's start again.
I gave you a bad start for this
because the kind of exercise
we just proposed is
better if you guys have
a little sounds
just ahead of it.
So you can actually--
you guys can
make a choice about
when to come in.
So let's start that again.
That was my fault
as director here.
All right, so same thing.
Inhabit the space.
Get in the space.
Come on.
Everybody in the space.
All right.
So you guys right now
pick who you're following.
Is everybody picked?
All right, and you
guys take a second.
Just pay attention to yourself.
Wait to feel like you want to
play something, and then play.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
INSTRUCTOR: Nice.
Nice.
Great ending, too.
Awesome.
All right, switch--
let's switch roles.
people People who have been
moving, get your instruments.
That was great.
The same exercise.
I'm just going to move this
back a little bit just in case
anybody gets enthusiastic.
All right, so we got movers?
AUDIENCE: Mhm.
INSTRUCTOR: Inhabit your space.
There you go.
AUDIENCE: OK.
INSTRUCTOR: All right.
Now pick who you're
going to follow.
Pick which instrumentalist
you're going to follow.
Now the people that are playing
instruments, take a moment.
And whenever you're ready.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
INSTRUCTOR: Excellent.
Just for balance,
let's do another one.
Same groups.
This time when we're
playing, I want
you to change the mood
of what you were playing.
So same thing.
You guys pick.
Pick a different person
then you picked before.
You got it?
All right.
You guys ready?
OK.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[LAUGHING]
INSTRUCTOR: Nice.
Nice work.
I must commend all of you.
Those are really hard
exercises to start off
the class-- for the first
class, because they're
very-- you know, you got
to do some weird stuff.
So I commend you.
Thank you for being so generous
if you were scared on that.
Let's have everybody
get our instruments.
We'll go onto something
else because I
wanted to get some
graphic stuff in
here too before we
have to leave today.
So that just gives
you some ideas.
Gets you into that universe of
like, oh, movement and sound.
They go together.
And if you watch, you can
watch like while you're
walking around.
Watch people as
they walk and talk.
Just look at nature.
See how sounds and
movements go together,
and that would give you
some interesting ideas
and some interesting things
to play with-- oh, OK.
They give you some
interesting things
to play with when you
start doing work with film.
All right, here,
you guys over there
because I'm going to draw
some things on the board.
So
I'm going to just do
some real quick things.
Just playing around with
gestures and graphic elements,
and what first
impressions of them are.
So we're just going to have
some fun playing with this.
So, you know, talking
about those kind
of graphic parameters.
So this-- what does
that sound like?
[STRUMMING INSTRUMENTS]
Right.
So there's a lot
of things-- there's
a lot of things like that.
That we just have
associations with, you know?
How about this?
[PLAYING INSTRUMENTS]
INSTRUCTOR: Interesting.
So there's some
interesting associations,
which is that we tend to
think of music visually.
Particularly if you've
grown up reading music.
That's up.
Up and down means the same
thing in whatever kind of space.
Whether you're working
in musical space
or you're working in
graphic space, you know?
Short and long-- We associate--
[PLAYING INSTRUMENTS]
Yeah, exactly.
This
[PLAYING INSTRUMENTS]
All right, and if I do this?
So short and long.
It's a parameter that
has a certain meaning.
Whether you're moving or
whether you're drawing
or whether you're
playing sounds.
Up and down.
High and low.
What would that be?
[INSTRUMENT STRUM]
What would this be?
[INSTRUMENTS PLAYING]
Right, right.
So all these kinds of
things have meaning.
And then there's things
that have-- so there's
all these different
parameters like that.
That we just have
associations with because
of our spatial awareness.
There's other ones that,
if you're a musician,
you might have a sense of.
I mean there's no accident
that that means what it does.
[STRUMMING INSTRUMENT]
What's that sound like?
[PLAYING INSTRUMENTS]
Good.
So let's do this.
I'm going to put up things--
I think this is fun.
So what I want to do is-- like
you've been doing-- play them,
but what I want you to do
is play them all together
as a group.
So I'll put it up
and then you guys,
I'll give you a
little space and then
you guys play it
together and stop.
And I'll put another one up.
We'll talk about
them a little bit.
Yeah, so crescendo, decrescendo.
We learned that in music
it means what it means,
but also graphically it quite
obviously means what it means.
And I think in math there's like
a greater or lesser thing going
on here, too, right?
Is that the same meaning
or a different one?
No?
AUDIENCE: Close enough.
INSTRUCTOR: Close enough?
What does that symbol mean?
AUDIENCE: Everything
on the right
is bigger than
everything on the left.
INSTRUCTOR: Oh, OK.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
INSTRUCTOR: OK.
Yup.
Yeah, so the volume would
be greater on the right than
on the left.
Yeah, so same thing.
Volume is greater here
in music than it is here.
Yeah, cool.
All right.
So here we'll just have some fun
and play some different ones.
I'll just conduct
you to begin and you
can end whenever you
feel like it ends.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
That's fun How about this?
Let's see.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
That's fun.
I've never done this before.
Let's see, let's see.
How about this.
What would you do if I did this?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Cool.
I figured I had
to do that or else
you'd just keep going and going.
It would never stop.
All right, let's see.
All right, we're
going to do this.
Ready?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
INSTRUCTOR: Good.
All right, so we're
going to-- I'm
going to add-- I think that
we could play with this
for a little bit and add a
couple other elements in here.
So let's play this
as if you're each
playing this sequence
individually at whatever pace
and whatever timing you want.
OK?
And it ends-- the
piece begins whenever
the first person starts.
The piece ends whenever
the last person ends.
You ready?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Great.
Awesome.
Good.
Let's play the same
thing, except now I
want you to all move as one.
Ready?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Good.
Now the interesting thing there,
and this is pretty much true
whenever movement is
involved is that if you're
trying to fall
somebody, or you're
trying to move as a
group, the first person
that moves controls
the movement.
Because this is--
if you're saying
we're all moving together, then
as soon as one person moves,
everybody else has to move.
Here, let's do this.
We'll add another part in.
Let's play that first.
What does that sound like?
[SQUIGGLY INSTRUMENT STRUMMING]
That's so weird that we
all have similar reactions
to these things.
OK, so-- I guess
not weird, really.
But it's interesting to me.
OK, so let's-- you can choose.
You can choose either to
play this part of this part.
So it'll be a two-part thing.
The people that are
playing each part,
I want you to play
your part together.
So there's two challenges.
One you have to
identify the people that
are playing your part
and stay with them.
OK.
Ready?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Cool.
So did you feel like you
knew who was playing what?
Yeah.
Who was playing what?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
INSTRUCTOR: Anybody else?
AUDIENCE: I feel like it
was kind of estranged.
I feel like if you want to have
everyone be on the same page,
then like-- this is at
least going through my head.
How are we going to time this?
And then is there a standard
way to read from left to right?
Approximately from
the time we finished
playing those first two
lines, whatever that means,
we kind of start the squiggly
thing, whatever that means.
Just because I assumed
that everyone else assumed
that assumed that, et cetera.
INSTRUCTOR: Right.
Yeah.
Well let's say-- let's
make that more explicit.
Because you're right.
People-- we are used to
as a culture moving from
left to right, but in
all kinds of reading.
And in music temporally you
move from left to right.
It indicates time.
In art, I'm not sure if that's
necessarily true since it's
more-- but definitely
in music you
tend to think that this is
the beginning, that's the end,
and we sort of been
playing that way all along.
So let's say specifically
this is the beginning.
Actually, let's do repeats.
We'll do it twice.
All right, so we are
going to play it twice.
That's the beginning.
That's the end.
So if you choose to do the
squigglies-- technical term,
the squigglies.
Remember that.
If you choose to do that, then
you're starting like a little
after the third note.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
INSTRUCTOR: No.
No.
It might be more
fun if you didn't.
OK, you ready?
You can start whenever you want.
I'm going to stop starting you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
INSTRUCTOR: Awesome.
That was great.
All right, let's
add a third part.
Anybody?
Any volunteers?
Want to add a third part?
[LAUGHTER]
INSTRUCTOR: Ooh.
OK, you ready?
Let's take the repeats
off this time, though.
Because I want to do a
couple more and we're
running out of time.
OK, you ready?
Whenever.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
INSTRUCTOR: That was cool.
All right, let's do another one.
We got time to do one more.
This is when I feel
really teachery where
I have to do blackboard.
All right.
First part-- let's
do three parts.
So key here is
make them specific.
Make them simple at this point.
Makes it easier.
Haha, did I blow your
thing [? there? ?]
No, no.
Go ahead.
Do what you want to do.
We'll see.
Oh yeah, that's simple.
Or not.
Oh.
It's like that ribbon candy.
Cool.
All right, what's
the second part?
INSTRUCTOR: Haha.
Good.
Let's do this one-- let's
split into-- let's do it
in two different groups.
Just to make it-- because
there's a lot of sound there.
So we'll just split it in half.
One, two, three, four, five.
You guys can split
up if you want to.
Would you rather do
that or play together?
All right.
Yeah, so you'll be one,
one, one, one, one.
AUDIENCE: Can I have one?
INSTRUCTOR: Yeah, sure.
AUDIENCE: All right.
INSTRUCTOR: Yeah.
All right, so you guys
go first and then--
let's see what they sound like.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
INSTRUCTOR: Good.
Now second group, same piece.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
INSTRUCTOR: Cool.
I think that's a
good place to stop.
All right, thank you.
So for this week
as you're just--
as you're walking
around, pay attention.
Pay attention to the
sound of movement
and how they go together in your
mind and outside of your mind.